(upbeat music)
- Ah he is gonna take your job, Jason.
Welcome back everybody. We
are here with Craig Robinson.
Give it up.
Come on over here, Craig.
You gotta play now.
His show is called "Harlem
Globetrotters: Play It Forward"
You can see it Saturdays on
"NBC" and in honor of that show,
it is time for a new game
called "Put the Sports
Ball Thru the Little Metal Hoop".
♪ Put the Sports Ball Thru
the Little Metal Hoop ♪
(laughing)
- 'Cause that's what we're doing.
Craig and I each have a teammate
from the Harlem Globetrotters.
On my team, give it up for Moose Weekes!
And playing with Craig, give
it up for Zeus McClurkin.
(makes buzzer sounds)
- Yeah, yeah.
- Alright, we need, we need a host.
Lord, are you there? Can you help us out?
(angelic music)
- Oh.
Yeah
- [Roberts] I am here,
Kelly. What's going on, girl?
- Living my best life.
- [Roberts] That's what I'm talking about.
Hey Craig. Hey Globetrotters.
How y'all doing?
- What up?
- [Roberts] Globe Trotters I
made you both in my own image,
that's for sure right there.
Okay, now the game is in the title.
The game is in the title.
You read the title.
That's the game. Okay, very simple.
In front of you, you have some balls.
You gotta sink as many balls as you can.
Now, if Craig and Zeus
win, their photos are going
up on The Chicks Wall of
Champs Who Beat Kelly Clarkson?
That's what I'm talking about.
- No one cares, Zeus.
- [Roberts] She's fierce.
She's a fierce competitor.
Better watch out, okay.
Now Moose and Zeus,
You up first all right?
- Okay.
- [Roberts] Now you're gonna shoot
until you hear the buzzer.
Okay, you guys ready?
- Are you ready?
- [Roberts] We're gonna
get the ball rolling.
Here we go and shoot.
- I'm gonna hand them.
I'll hand them. Okay.
(bell dings)
- [Roberts] There you go.
(inaudible)
- [Roberts] Throw them balls, uh huh.
- [Weekes] Oh hold on. Oh, oh.
- [Roberts] There you go.
- Whoa, Kelly, Kelly!
- [Clarkson] No, Oh my
Roberts! Oh my Roberts!
- [Roberts] Two seconds left here.
- I'm not even walking.
(horn blows and bell dings)
- [Roberts] Alright
- [Weekes] Look at the
backboard. Oh my goodness.
- Is it done?
- [Weekes] This is crazy.
- [Roberts] That's it.
- Oh, oh we need more balls.
- [Roberts] That's it, we out of time.
Oh, it's done. Okay.
- [Roberts] Craig and Zeus, you really
cleaned up on that round. You got six.
You got six there. So you looking good.
You ahead of the game.
- [Clarkson] Okay, Okay, I wasn't even
paying attention. I was so focused.
- [Roberts] Very, very good.
Cutting loose over there. Okay.
- Okay.
- [Roberts] Kelly and Craig.
- [Roberts] You see how it's done?
The balls are in your court.
- What? What? What? What? What?
- [Roberts] Get ready.
- We gonna carry this, Kelly.
- [Clarkson] Yeah.
- [Roberts] And here we go.
Shoot. Go for it. Come on now.
(rock music)
- Oh my God!
- Yeah, right there.
- I can't with the backboard.
- [McClurkin] Yeah there we go.
- Ahhh!
- [Roberts] That's what I'm talking about.
- Aim for the backboard. You got it, yeah.
(bell dings)
- Grab some fire. Grab some fire.
(horn blows)
- Let's go!
- [Roberts] And that's time right there.
(clapping)
- [Roberts] Let's take
a look at the score.
Now we count up the numbers for you and
it looks like Kelly and
Moose, you got five.
Craig and Zeus, you got 12. Unbelievable.
- We got five. Five.
- [Clarkson] I think I only got two.
- [Roberts] That's what I'm talking about.
Now, it's still anybody's game.
- Okay.
- [Roberts] And I'm gonna
make things a little
bit more interesting here.
Okay.
- [Roberts] Moose and
Zeus, you're up again,
but this time Justin and Marcel
gonna bring out some balls.
Okay. Justin, where's Justin and Marcel.
Get out here. Bring out some crazy balls.
- Wait, what?
- [Roberts] We're gonna mix it up for you.
- I guess this is why it's "Sports Ball".
- Okay.
- [Roberts] We ain't doing basketballs.
- You are-
- [Roberts] We're doing
random sports balls this time
because I'm God and I make this stuff up.
- Yes!
- [Roberts] There it is.
- [Weekes] Now we're gonna take the lead.
- [Clarkson] This is where we come in.
- [Roberts] Bring out those
balls, those biggity balls.
Okay. Come on now. Okay,
Moose and Zeus. You ready?
- Let's get it.
- [Roberts] Here we go. Ready and shoot.
(bell dings)
- Yeah! Come on, yeah.
- [Roberts] Looking good. Good form.
(bell dings)
- [Roberts] Keep going for it.
- [Roberts] Throw a football in there.
(bells dings)
- [Roberts] Rainbow
colored football? Okay.
- All right, all right!
(bells dings)
- All right!
(horn blows)
- [Roberts] And that's time.
- Coming back Kelly.
- Yeah!
- Oh yeah.
- ...buzzer
- [Roberts] Some good
time. Oh, Craig and Zeus
still got, got 14. So
you're still in the lead.
Craig and Zeus you got 14.
- You came back. You came back.
- We came back.
- [Roberts] That's right. That's right.
- Okay, wait need more
ball. Wait don't start yet.
- [Roberts] Tossing them uh-
- I see a lot of just normal
basketballs over here.
- That's not normal. Those are
normals. These are different.
- [Roberts] Those are abnormal.
Yeah. Mix those balls up fellas.
Okay. All right, you ready now?
Okay, here we go. We're
gonna toss them freaky balls.
Here we go. Get ready and shoot.
- Let's go, Craig.
(bell dings)
- [Weekes] There we go. There we go.
- [Roberts] Lots of tension here.
- I'm gonna slow down.
- [Roberts] Balls to the wall.
(bell dings)
- Keep going. Keep going.
(horn blows)
- Here we go. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Roberts] Oh, and that's
it. That's the buzzer.
- The don't count. That's after-
- [Roberts] The game is
over and we have a winner,
Craig and Zeus, with 19.
Kelly and Moose with 15.
They kept their eye on the ball.
- I would like to
apologize to my teammate.
I'm not good at sports
ball. Craig and Zeus won.
So that means that they get their photos
on The Chicks Wall of Champs
Who Beat Kelly Clarkson.
Yeah. Congratulations. Whatever.
Thanks for playing everybody.
Be sure to watch "Harlem
Globetrotters: Play It Forward"
Saturdays on "NBC". You can also
see Craig in "Killing It" on "Peacock".